il a toujours été fort et s'est toujours
battu pour sa famille il avait envie de
rien lâcher vous connaissez un dollar
était pour le travail aussi bien ils
n'étaient pas en retraite en fin de
compte c'était un boulimique de travail
il s'inquiétait toujours pour la famille
de tf1 ils veulent être sûrs que ce soit
bien fait moi j'aurais fait comme ça moi
j'avais voilà c'est ça c'est lui qui
voulait remercier tout son public tous
ces gens tous ces messages d'amour pour
tous ses remerciements pour les fleurs
à tanis voilà qu'on aime j'espère
qu'elle sera avec nous dans les
prochains jours parce qu'on voulait
vraiment être avec elle parce qu'on
l'aimé franchement bravo à elf à quelle
force et leur caractère mais je sais je
sais qu'elle a fait ça parce que elle
savait que jean pierre aurait aimé qu'on
pas qu'elle prenne sur elle pour parler
à à tf1 au jt de tf1 et aux équipes de
tf1 quelle force de caractère dans ce
moment aussi difficile et et voilà on
voit à quel point c'est dit c'est dur
pour elle mais qu'elle prend sur elle
malgré tout pour lui fait c'est une
interview très touchante qui résume bien
jean pierre pernaut pour moi quelqu'un
de passionné par son travail qui vivait
vraiment pour sa passion pour les
régions et pour le journalisme en
revanche assez peu intéressés par la
notorité son statut de star elle dit à
un moment qui pensaient que les gens
l'oublierai très vite après son départ
du jt ce qui est pas vrai mais c'est
comme une vraie preuve d'humilité de
simplicité de sa part clément garde
qu'est ce qui s'est passé sur le gt1
comme en chine que vous avez toutes les
infos mais comme il a quitté de jt vous
voulez dire oui voyez mais quand il a
quitté les jt c'est on va dire que c'est
il a accepté de quitter le jt mais
c'était pas vraiment est-ce que non
parce que je veux dire c'est une classe
immense gens perdent leur nom je le
redis encore si le mec qui a le plus la
classe du graff c'est à dire que il vous
ai vu il ya des mecs qui sont horrifiés
des caisses par lui il a pas bien mûri
là il est ici pour ça que voilà une
religion en fait un septembre avec
gilles béni hssen filippini sommes là il
a fait comprendre qu'il voulait un
nouveau sous donner un nouveau souffle
au trésor et jean pierre qui aurait très
bien pu insister qui aurait très bien pu
alors j'avais dit aussi je reste encore
quelques années voilà il était après
nathalie derrière le pousser à arrêter
aux sirènes emballé
donc plutôt que d'avoir une
communication sur jean pierre pernaut
viré du trésor où il a préféré faire sa
propre sortie et c'était tout à son
honneur parce qu'il est chaud pour
continuer non plus non non mais voilà
avec sa famille d'autres jean-pierre
qu'on aime fort bien entendu et ont pour
ce très fort à nathalie et à six enfants